let's imagine that we that SETI the
search for extraterrestrial intelligence
suppose it pays off and we start getting
overhearing eavesdropping on or actually
communicating with getting
communications from another another
civilization of some sort somewhere in
the universe and we ask ourselves what
would surprise us and what would we
expect and what we would expect is that
they would have arithmetic and they
would agree with us that two plus two
equals four and they'd have geometry and
they would there was a lot of things
that they would have would they have a
base-10 arithmetic probably not or
because why well because we are pretty
sure that the reason that we have
base-10 arithmetic is because we've got
two of these with five of these and if
if we had only three fingers and the
thumb on each hand and we would have
base eight arithmetic of course it might
turn out that they had base 10
arithmetic because having two of these
with five of these is a better trick
than we realize it's not just a
historical accident but something that's
a sort of a deep design reason why that
would be discovered again and again and
again by evolution I mean I sight I
think if the planet on which this life
exists has has a transparent atmosphere
then eyesight is such an obviously good
trick to have because it permits
distel it permits you to get information
from distant objects very fast that's
got to be good it gives you an advanced
warning system about what's out there
there's many good tricks I capitalize
the G in the team good tricks in design
space and what a good trick is is
something that will be discovered again
and again and again there's multiple
paths to it it's just such a good idea
that evolution will find it whenever
it's available
and I think that we can rely on that
principle to anticipate and I think we
do anyway I think for instance science
fiction writers and and filmmakers when
they imagine extraterrestrial creatures
they they help themselves to a lot of
features which they think well it's got
to be this way and now maybe maybe
you've covered with scales and maybe
have three heads but but there's some
things that you're definitely going to
have I think it's not just the demands
of storytelling I think there's a an
appreciation with why some of these
features are really our features uh-huh
there are things that that no
intelligent agent would be caught dead
without because they're so useful I
think we can use that sort of reverse
engineering thinking to extrapolate
quite a bit about what we could find out
in the in the rest of the universe
well like many other people I fall back
on
Philip Morrison's observation that
there's two possibilities that we're
alone in the universe and that we're not
and they're both mind-boggling and I
really don't have a very strong opinion
about which is the truth I am inclined
toward thinking that we're not alone but
that's based on sort of impressionistic
probably probabilistic thinking I mean
we've seen on this planet that say sight
has evolved not once not twice but many
times flying has evolved locomotion is
evolved more than once every case of
convergent evolution of this sort is an
important denim that suggests that
there's certain sorts of things which if
they can't happen they will happen now
the question is are there are places
elsewhere in the universe where the
opportunity is available and I think
it's hard to imagine that there are